all right i'm going to pitch up on this
wall right here in the pvc munich
just come straight over to me farron
alex paul stab
vest under his coat is loitering in a
dimly lit car park in south east london
hoping to take possession of a samurai
sword
he's arranged to meet a man who's
confiscated it from a young friend
too frightened to hand it in himself
what
i'm going to do i'll take the thing now
so you can get off the roadside
and then i'm just going to go for the
taking it and then i'll keep it moving
for you
while farron gets the huge knife to a
safe place
we find out why handing it to police
directly
is not an option if i didn't know about
him
that knife will still do on the roads
right now which i mean
touch what they could have been used by
my soul we need more people like him
people want people don't want to live
this life let's just live this life
that's what people need to understand
well why wouldn't you take it to the
police
no no no that's not no no no no but the
police think there
ain't nobody they'll probably point the
finger at me i'll leave my
house a bit within two minutes they were
searching anyway to find it with me
how would i then explain what my purpose
clearly anxious he explains why the
youngster had the sword in the first
place
he's growing up in a tough neighborhood
not everyone has
the same opportunities you know
family love all of that stuff so you
fall into a gang and you fall part of it
so
obviously a young man like him needs
someone
who can be that figure to say yo you can
actually do something else give me that
anyone would hand it over i'll tell you
that right now
around the corner farron shows us the
weapon this has been sharpened that you
can talk you see the bits down there
don't touch it don't touch it don't
touch it because i don't know where it's
spinning you don't know it's been that's
why it goes on yeah all right
but you can see how sharp it is it's
staggering and terrifying that blades
like this are being carried on our
streets
but farron has handed in dozens of them
are you seeing this
this is what this is what a single mom
confiscated you see this
mad thing the end of the road for the
samurai sword
is plumstead police station
farron waits as the knife is carefully
encased in a sealed tube
before explaining what was going on i
run a knife amnesty and
basically people give me nice i live in
north london
i picked up in village and i thought
it'd be very stupid to start driving at
halfway across back london
so i just thought to myself i'll come to
the nursery station and
job danny told us why a father of two
young children
puts his life on the line time and again
mate the way i see it yeah if the knife
ain't on the street it can't be in
someone's hand and if you can't be in
someone's hand yet
it can't stab someone because you have
been attacked with a knife haven't you
yeah i've been attacked enough yeah
two times two separate occasions just
tell us what happened
i just got into altercation regarding my
sister
i was defending my sister and another
time i defended my girlfriend
and i got stabbed nine times on two
different occasions
this blade is now off the streets many
many more are still out there with
people
prepared to kill and they're unlikely to
hand them over directly
to police debbie bowden sky news in
southeast london